where does freedom come from if we don't
have any kind of physics-based free will
yeah and and so the idea
follows naturally from all that we've
been talking about let's make the
assumption
that all there is in the physical
universe is stuff governed by laws we
may not have those laws may may not know
what the fundamental stuff is yet
but everything we know in science points
in the direction that it's physical
stuff governed by universal laws
and
that being the case or that being the
assumption then you come to a particular
collection of those ingredients called a
human being and that human being has
particles that are fully governed by
physical law
and when you then recognize that every
thought that we have every action that
we undertake is just the motion of
particles when i'm thinking thoughts
right now of course at this level of
description
it is the motion of particles cascading
down various neurons inside of my head
and so on and every single one of those
motions collectively and individually is
fully governed by these laws that we
perhaps don't have yet but we imagine
one day we will that leaves no
opportunity for any kind of freedom to
break free from the constraint of
physical law and that is the end of the
story so the traditional intuitive
notion of free will that we're the
ultimate authors of our actions that
where the buck stops that there is no
antecedent that is the cause for our
decided to go left or right choose
vanilla or chocolate live or die
that intuitive sensation does not have a
basis in our understanding of the
physical world so that's the end of the
free will of the traditional sword but
then your question is
what about this other kind of freedom i
talk about and the other kind of freedom
if you focus on it intently i think
is actually
the true version of freedom that we feel
and that freedom is this
you look at inanimate objects in the
world rocks bottles of water whatever
they have a very limited behavioral
repertoire why
their internal organization is too
coarse for them to do very much right
you have to you try to have a
conversation with a glass of water you
send sound waves it doesn't do much it
may vibrate a little bit but the
repertoire of responses are incredibly
limited
the difference between us and a rock or
a bottle of water is that our inner
organization by virtue of eons of
evolution by natural selection is so
refined so spectacularly ordered that we
have a huge repertoire of behaviors that
are finely attuned to stimuli from the
external world you ask me a question
that's a stimulus and all of a sudden
these particle processes go into action
and this
is the result this answer that i'm
giving you so the freedom that we have
is not from
the control of physical law the freedom
that we have is from the constrained
behavior that has long since governed
inanimate objects we are liberated from
the limited behavioral repertoire of
rocks and bottles of water
to have this broad spectrum of responses
do we pick them we do not do we freely
choose them we do not
but yet we have them and we can marvel
at those behaviors and that's the
freedom that we have the complexity and
the breadth of that repertoire is is
where the freedom
you